If you want to my theory on why Chucky willingly
decided to mutilate himself towards the end of
the movie then stick around to the end of
this video.
Welcome back to Things You Missed, in the
last episode I covered the original Child’s
Play -- you can check that out here if you
want -- so this time let’s reopen the toybox
and take a stab at Child’s Play 2.
This one opens up by showing the aftermath
that the events of the first movie had on
the company that makes the Good Guy dolls:
Play Pal Toys, and their boss, Mr. Sullivan.
As the President of a major toy company, Mr.
Sullivan has a custom license plate that says:
“FUN ONE”.
The other executive is later shown to have
license plate “EXEC 4”.
We will see more of Mr. Sullivan and a little
bit about why he’s known as The Fun One
in the next sequel, but in this movie, he’s
not in the mood for fun and games.
You know, ‘hi, I’m Chucky, I’m the Lakeshore
Strangler and I’m gonna kill you’....
Well, something like that.”
The opening title this time takes on a new
look as compared to the previous movie, this
time it looks a lot like the font seen the
badges that the employees of Play Pal Toys
wear.
The Chucky doll from the last movie is cleaned
up and restored using a variety of instruments,
including actual dental tools, which reminds
me of that one guy from Toy Story 2, who is
apparently big with the ASMR community.
“The part where he paints woody's shoe with
the paint brush.
Oooooofff.”
“And I thought I was the only one satisfied
by this scene…”
“this is my favorite scene from Toy Story
2, it's so aesthetically pleasing omgahhhh”
OK, enough of that, but this one of the many
connections between the two franchises -- such
as the protagonist being a kid named Andy
and the 2019 installments sharing a release
date on June 21st.
The new Child’s Play even has a poster that's mocking
is Pixar counterpart.
So Chucky’s body is restored.
I don’t really know why they felt the need
to fix up THIS particular doll -- they could
have just produced a new doll named Chucky
and shown that to their stockholders instead.
It would have been a lot less work.
But no, had to go with the cursed one, and
of course, things go wrong.
[electrocution clip]
“Ah **** here we go again.”
We are then reintroduced to Andy Barclay,
who is now at a foster home after his mom
was put away in the looney bin.
Andy has a bad dream about Chucky.
“You know dreams can’t hurt ya.
Dreams aren’t real, right?”
Apparently this guy has never seen A Nightmare
on Elm Street.
Andy ends up getting adopted by The Simpsons.
No, not those Simpsons, we’ll save them
for my Treehouse of Horror episodes of Things
You Missed.
THESE Simpsons are known for taking many foster
children over the years, and their walls are
painted in baby blue and pink -- the colors
commonly associated with a nursery -- to reflect
that.
Andy takes a look around the house.
"You like it?"
"Uh-huh."
“It’s been in my family for three generations.
My grandmother gave it to my mother and my
mother gave it to me.”
“And who are you gonna give it to?”
Daaannngggg this kid just lit her on FIRE!
It would not be long before she got her revenge
though.
“I made those curtains just for you.
I bet blue is your favorite color.”
So let me get this straight.
You made the curtains specifically for Andy,
and yet you left a Good Guy doll in the closet,
knowing full well he has PTSD with Good Guy
dolls?
I mean what the hell is that?
Also found in the closet, is this skateboard
known as the Nash Nightmare Board from the
80s.
It’s decorated with a character that looks
like Jason from Friday the 13th, and the name
Nightmare Board is a bit of a nod to Freddy
Krueger’s franchise that I mentioned a minute
ago -- A Nightmare on Elm Street.
The other faces on the board just seem to
be generic horror characters.
That night, Chucky tries to get more information
about Andy Barclay’s location and he calls
the foster home.
A little boy named Sammy asks the caretaker
to play a game called “red light.”
“I wanna play Red Light.”
“No Sammy, I don’t want to play Red Light
now I want you to back to bed right now.”
This is one of many references to traffic
lights in this movie.
Andy has a shirt with traffic lights on it
and there seems to be an emphasis on them
in some of the shots.
I’m not 100% sure on what the meaning of
these are -- perhaps just a hint that Chucky
will be riding in vehicles during the climax
of this movie.
Also, the blood-red phone that connects Chucky
and the foster home lady could be a clue about
later.
Andy’s new foster mother reads him Hansel
and Gretel as a bedtime story, but she gets
West Dakota level lazy and just kind of skips
to the happily ever after part.
“...and they all live happily ever after.”
“No they don’t!”
“They do for now, we’ll finish it tomorrow
night.”
I almost wonder if this is kind of a clue
that maybe at the time Child’s Play 2 was
made, it was supposed to be a trilogy.
We get our happily ever after at the end of
2 -- but in reality, we finish things up in
three where Chucky is finished off once and
for all.
We now know that that doesn’t happen, but
it does still hold true to this era of Child’s
Play movies being a set of three.
After Child’s Play 3, the series totally
shifts towards full-comedy, and the movies
take on a different naming scheme.
I think a lot of people see the first three
as a set -- then Bride and Seed as a set,
and finally Curse and Cult as a third era.
When Chucky buries the other Good Guy doll
known as Tommy, he uses a Toy Shovel, which
is in line with the Good Guy accessories seen
being sold in the first movie.
Play Pal Toys unknowingly gave Chucky a whole
arsenal of weapons it seems.
Andy’s new parents are concerned by his
behaviour and have a discussion about him
in the kitchen.
OK, seriously, how do they not hear him eavesdropping
right here?
This episode is already turning into Shaggy
Questions The Logic of Horror Movies Part
II.
And honestly, you guys are here for it aren’t
you?
Alright let’s try to move on.
OH WOW.
OK.
This would be a realllllyyyy bad look in 2019.
Let’s actually skip ahead a little further
to……
Andy going on the school bus.
There should actually be some Things You Missed
in this scene.
So Andy gets on the bus and several kids are
wearing Good Guys merchandise.
And this one kid is extremely hostile!
Wow, what did Andy do to you dude?
Somebody call Jake Paul, we’ve got a cyberbully.
Or actually just a regular bully I guess.
Andy’s teacher, Mrs. Kettlewell reads a
story to the class.
She’s reading Pinocchio, the tale of a puppet
who is turned into a real boy, a clear parallel
to Chucky being a toy who is turned into a
real human at the end of the movie.
Chucky sabotages Andy’s schoolwork, earning
him a detention after school.
Are you kidding me, the teacher locks him
in there?
What if there’s a fire?
What if there’s a gas leak and he needs
to get out?
Yeah, not the best idea -- so when Chucky
kills her with a ball pump (if you were wondering
what that was) she almost kind of deserves
it.
Andy is able to get home safely though, and
Mr. Simpson is getting fed up with the stories
about Chucky.
“Open the door.
OPEN IT!
“Hey V-Sauce, Michael here.”
Andy gets the meat carver that night and decides
to take matters into his own hands, but Phil
hears the commotion and comes down to investigate,
unfortunately becoming the next victim of
Chucky.
The woman from the foster home has to come
and pick up Andy and Kyle, as they’ll no
longer be able to stay in this home.
As she’s explaining things to him, there’s
a carousel in the background.
This is probably just a random set piece to
go along with the clowns seen in the upstairs
bedroom, but the analytical side of my brain
likes to see this as a symbol for Andy’s
current state of life, how he’s constantly
being thrown back into this loop that just
goes around and around in cycles of being
assigned to a new home, getting attacked by
Chucky, getting sent back to the nursing home
and then getting assigned to yet another new
home; never escaping the danger and constantly
going around and around like a Merry-Go-Round.
But then I remember, it’s a movie about
a killer children’s toy and probably doesn’t
go that deep.
Kyle discovers the other Good Guy doll that
Chucky buried earlier, but gets ambushed by
him before she can do anything.
He forces her to drive to the foster home,
but they get pulled over on the way.
Lucky for her, he’s a fan of Good Guy dolls
I guess…?
And he asks what the doll’s name is.
“Chucky.”
*laughter*
Hold up, how would the cop not realize something
was up here?
I mean they’ve already established that the events
of the first movie were all over the news.
And I imagine the company would not continue
to name any dolls “Chucky” after their
little PR disaster.
Well, anyways, he doesn’t seem to notice
anything is up, and Chucky makes it to the
foster home, where he pulls the fire alarm
to try to smoke out Andy as quickly as possible.
The kids file out, and I noticed many of them
are wearing Good Guys shirts.
Again, you’d think they might be encouraged
NOT to wear those because of the whole Andy
PTSD thing.
Seems a little bit rude.
Also, one of the kids had on a Bon Jovi shirt
-- which I just now noticed and coincidentally
has nothing to do with the fact that I said
Bon Jovi would have made a perfect closing
track during the Things You Missed episode
for the first movie even though they didn’t
put it in.
Swear I didn’t plan this, I literally just
noticed the Bon Jovi shirt during this video.
So Andy freezes on the stairs when he spots
Chucky.
Not sure why he didn’t just stay with the
group, it probably would have been a lot safer since Chucky
doesn’t like to reveal himself as a living
doll, but as we know, Andy isn’t the smartest
kid either.
So Chucky kills that lady and escapes with
Andy.
Whatever kid drew this dinosaur was obviously very
confused, this is clearly not a T-Rex…
Actually it was probably Andy who drew that.
Now there’s one part in the newspaper truck
here that I need to pause at, not to explain
a Thing You Missed, but rather so I can say
DAAAAA BEARS.
So Kyle is chasing Chucky and Andy,
because this movie has character arcs and
I guess she actually cares about the little
snot head now.
She runs the truck driver off the road and
it just happens to be right near the factory,
so one obvious Indiana Jones reference later,
we’re inside the factory.
This is actually the best part of the movie,
so pay attention.
Chucky does the voodoo spell on Andy once
again, causing the storm clouds to roll in.
Tom Skilling must have been losing his g*******
mind during these movies.
The spell doesn’t work because Chucky was
too late, he’s already become human, so
he goes for the next best thing: revenge.
“Some BODY”.
Ok, but actually right here we get a better
look at the box, and it’s the same mistake
from the last movie where it says Play Partners
Toys instead of Play Pals.
We also get a better look at the side of the
box which notes that batteries are included.
The working title for the original Child’s
Play was “Batteries Not Included”, but
then I guess they decided they wanted the
batteries to be included for that whole plot
point about Andy’s Mom realizing that Chucky
was operating without the batteries, so they
changed it, and added this to the box.
As Andy and Kyle run away, I noticed this
box is already ripped, but they haven’t
even done anything over here yet.
Talk about bad quality control Play Pal Toys.
Andy and Kyle flee up this ramp, and Chuckers
gets the old arm trapped under this gate.
Not sure why he doesn’t just open the gate,
he’s shown some strength in the past and
it really doesn’t look that heavy, but he
decides, ‘you know what?
I’m pulling my arm off.’
Maybe he really wanted to have a knife for
an arm and he did it on purpose.
Like ever since he was 7 and he realized his
punches don’t do that much damage, he just
decided right then and there: ‘When I grow
up, I’m gonna have a knife for an arm, and
there’s nothing you can do about it Mom!’
So then we get to this machine, which apparently
produces mangled up monster toys, and they
staple Chucky down to it and he seemingly
dies.
Except this is a Child’s Play movie, and
like the previous one, he comes back.
So they melt him alive.
And he comes back.
So this time they blow up his head, and I
guess that works.
It just ends pretty abruptly.
Much like this video, if you want to see the
Things You Missed in the next movie, that
video will be on the left once the video comes
out later this week.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring the deathbell for
notifications and I’ll see you in the next
one.
Assuming we both survive.